right you'll float too a brand new it  themed escape room experience is coming  to the valley this fall escape it as  it's called promises 30 000 square feet  of special effects scare actors and more  now guests will feel like they're in the  movie as they visit iconic locations  like the losers clubhouse and nebolt  house as they try and escape pennywise  you know the the dancing clown there in  the in the film now the company behind  the attraction says it'll be located  just about five minutes from the strip  no word yet on tickets but of course  we'll keep you posted pennywise is so  freaky  i'm not going there it's too scary for  me